florida the fight between disney and the
governor over a controversial new law
that limits discussion of sexual
identity in public schools is escalating
republican lawmakers are close to
passing a measure to end a special tax
district for disney manuel bajorkas is
following this story and joins us now
live from orlando good morning manuel
good morning disney initially did not
take an official stance but once the
governor signed that law and disney
employees protested it cited against the
republican leadership this week in a
special session those leaders vowed to
take away disney's special district
when disney world was still just an idea
the disney family lobbied florida
officials to create a special
improvement district governed by disney
and called reedy creek
it taxes itself to provide roads power
and some emergency services that was
1967
this was the governor's call to
lawmakers this week but they also will
be considering termination of all
special districts that were enacted in
florida prior to 1968. the move comes
after disney publicly condemned
florida's parental rights and education
law which critics call don't say gay
because it prohibits public school
instruction on topics related to sexual
orientation or gender identity in grades
k-3 is this retaliation
no i don't think so but i think that
when you kick the hornet's nest i think
sometimes issue rise up that you weren't
aware of republican state representative
randy fine co-sponsored the bill to
strip disney the state's largest private
employer of self-governing status
disney's charter allows them to build a
nuclear power plant it allows them to
build roads without having to follow
florida department of transportation
standards these are not things that may
make a lot of sense maybe they did 55
years ago but they don't today find
claims taxpayers won't end up footing
the bill if disney's status goes away
but some say local residents could still
end up paying for it while the
district's one billion dollar debt from
bonds remains an open question it's kind
of shocking that they would come after
disney for this says aubry jewett a
political science professor at the
university of central florida if they do
it to disney who's been so supportive of
republicans over the last 20 years and
so important to florida's economy then
who wouldn't they do it too
if this becomes law disney can
renegotiate with lawmakers still some
question the timing of this bill
alleging it's a distraction from the
governor's redrawing of the state's
congressional map which could give
republicans four more seats at the
expense of three from democrats tony
it's politics all the way down manny
thank you very much